I remember looking into fasting because
it's been a common interest for years
just in the last few years has been an
explosion of research into intermittent
fasting water only fasting five two
twenty five five time restricted feeding
all these tremendous literature and
what's interesting about the
intermittent fasting literature some
studies so it's great for you other
studies so it's terrible for you has all
these negative metabolic consequences
and it turns out it's timing early
versus late so when do you break the
fast so your window so if your window is
late you get the negative biological
consequence of eating at night and
shifting your calories towards later in
the day and so people that skip
breakfast I had these negative metabolic
effects of time restricted feeding
whereas people that did early time
restrictive feeding not only got the
chronobiological benefits of shifting
their calories towards the beginning of
the day they also got the time
restricted feeding benefits if you miss
any meal it should be supper not
breakfast right breakfast is called
Break fast for a reason